un drone en vol dans la nef de
Notre-Dame de Paris l'image date de
janvier 2017 un moment rare et au
command d'une entreprise nivernaise apex
drone avait été missionné à l'époque
pour prendre des photographies du tapis
de cœur de la cathédrale un souvenir
impérissable pour Laurent bear
techniquement c'était c'était
fantastique c'était fantastique ce sera
à refaire je le feraiis sans sans
hésiter c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué c'était un petit peu stressant
c'était intimidant mais c'était une
c'était une une épreuve une aventure
fantastique aujourd'hui après l'incendie
ces images deviennent un témoignage
elles permettent de redécouvrir notre
Dame comme on ne la verra peut-être plus
à l'identique d'autant que prendre de la
hauteur apporter des sensations inédites
une autre perspective et des points de
vue jusqu'à présent que que personne
n'avait pu voir ou alors il aurait fallu
se promener avec une très très grande
échelle vous savez que la voûe de
Notre-Dame si mes souvenirs sont bon fa
peu près 30 m personne n'était parti
observer depuis la création de NotreDame
peut-être les bâtisseurs ils avaient
encore leurs échafaudages à l'intérieur
mais personne n'avait pu contempler le
le sol de la cathédrale sous cet angle
et ça de ce côté-là c'est c'était unique
seul regret pour Laurent Birs ne pas
avoir enemmagasiné encore plus d'images
pouvoir voler sous les voûtes de la
cathédrale était un privilège une
occasion unique qui prend 2 ans plus
tard une valeur
patrimoniale